president Trump meantime called Russia's
president yesterday to say thank you
they spoke after Vladimir Putin's
year-end session with reporters where
the White House says he acknowledged
America's strong economic performance
Elizabeth Palmer attended Putin's news
conference she is outside the Kremlin in
Moscow with the latest Elizabeth good
morning good morning
not only did President Putin mention
those booming financial markets he gave
credit for them directly to President
Donald Trump in this four hour long
marathon press conference President
Putin had nothing good to say about
America but he did praised Donald Trump
he dismissed the Russian allegations of
women meddling in the American election
as just the work of people opposed to
Donald Trump who wanted to undermine his
legitimacy which by the way is exactly
the explanation used by the White House
this lining up with President Trump and
criticizing America is a very good way
for President Putin who still sees the
u.s. as an enemy of exacerbating the
turmoil and divide in American politics
Gale Elizabeth Palmer reporting from
Moscow thank you